The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today,
what we want to do
is finish off our discussion
of Lotka-Volterra competition
models.
So starting with this
idea of the two species
interacting competitively
but then moving on to try to
think about the
general properties
of Lotka-Volterra systems.
In particular, when
you have more species,
the kinds of dynamics
that you can get.
Also, we're going to talk
about these non-transitive
interactions, which are the
rock-paper-scissors type
interactions that may facilitate
the maintenance of diversity
in populations or
ecosystems, in particular,
in the presence of some
sort of spatial structure.
And so we'll talk both
about this demonstration
of rock-paper-scissors
type interactions
in the context of
male mating strategies
in lizards, this paper
that was by Curt Lively.
And then we'll talk
about another paper
in the microbial realm,
where they showed that there
are rock-paper-scissors type
interactions in the context
of colicin production,
toxin production
in the context of bacteria.
Then, at the end, we'll talk
about these population waves.
There was a rather
mathematical reading
that I had originally proposed,
but then we kind of switched
things up a bit, so
that you could, instead,
read that rock-paper-scissors
paper-- that is confusing--
that I think is maybe more fun.
But I'll tell you kind of this
basic idea of the population
waves, what happens, if you have
a combination of some growth
process together with
some effective diffusion,
you can get these
population waves that
correspond to this process
of range expansion,
where a population expands
into new territory.
I just started by
putting up what
we had from the last class.
So this is the two species
Lotka-Volterra competition
model.
So what we found was that,
for this to be competition,
for the species to be kind
of bad for each other,
that that corresponds to
the betas being positive.
Now, what we found is
there are four cases
in terms of the outcome of
this two species interaction.
And we wanted to,
at least, try to get
some sense of why that was
and what the trajectories
might look like.
If you look at and N1 and N2,
we can draw these nullclines
and then get a sense of
where the trajectories are
going to go.
Now, the basic outcome of this
two species Lotka-Volterra
competition model are
really exactly the same
as the possible
outcomes when we're
thinking about frequency
dependent selection, where
we could get, in this case, that
species 1 dominates or species
2 dominates, 1 or 2.
But then we could also get
coexistence or bi-stability.
And indeed, there
is, in general,
a mapping from the
Lotka-Volterra kind of approach
here and the approach that
was kind of in Martin Nonwak's
book of thinking about
frequency dependent selection
in this population.
And so then it's not
a surprise that you
get the same four outcomes
between these two situations.
And I think that this
is also highlighting
some very interesting and deep
connections between evolution,
which is changes in, say,
allele frequency in a population
of a single species,
over time, and then
some of these ecological kind of
processes, where you're really
thinking about these
as different species.
Now, of course, in the case
of the evolutionary dynamics
that we analyze Martin's
book, though, those
were the evolution of
different clonal populations
in asexually
reproducing populations.
Do you guys remember
what I'm talking about?
All right.
So I just want to draw a couple
of these sorts of diagrams.
I'm not going to draw
out all four of them,
because it does take some time.
But hopefully, we can
reconstruct where we were.
The case that we were analyzing
before, the N1 dot equals 0.
We're going to have
it as a dashed line.
And N2 is going to
be-- well, maybe
we'll try to use thick chalk.
Oh, wow, I missed.
These are thick lines.
So we'll draw these
nullclines over here.
So the N1 dot-- and
indeed, one of the comments
is that it would be nice to
draw where the nullclines are
on the axes as well.
And indeed, we can do that.
We aim to please.
So the dashed lines correspond
to N1 dot being to 0.
So here's N1, N2.
So N1 equal to 0
corresponds to this thing.
And then we have this other
guy that's a line, here.
Now what we found is
that, if N2 is equal to 0,
this intersects at K1, whereas
the intersection over here
is at K1 divided by beta 12.
Now, we have our
other nullclines
that correspond to
N2 dot equal to 0.
Now one of those lines is
indeed going to be along here.
And the other line
can fall-- there
are four different
possibilities for how
we might draw it in relation
to this N1 dot equal to 0
nullcline.
And depending on the
orientation of that,
we'll end up getting these four
different possible outcomes
of 1 dominating, irrespective
of the initial conditions,
2 dominating, irrespective
of initial conditions,
or coexistence or bi-stability.
So bi-stability is
the only-- so if you
start with a finite number
of each of these two species,
then bi-stability is the only
case where the outcome depends
on the starting condition.
So, of course, if you start out
without one of the two species,
then you won't get creation
of those species, right?
Because the only way to
get creation of species 1
is to have some species 1
individual in this model.
So we're going to get another
line, here, corresponding to N2
dot equal to 0.
And I think that the one that
we were trying to analyze
was with the solid
line underneath.
Is that consistent
with people's notes?
So we can draw some
other line here.
It doesn't have
to the same slope.
Now it's good to be
clear about where
these things are going to fall.
So K2 is this point.
And now K2 divided by
beta 21 is over here.
Now recall that beta
12 is telling us
about how much
species 2 is reducing
the growth of species 1.
Whereas beta 21 is
how much species
1 is reducing the
growth of species 2.
Now, everything comes down
to the relative ordering
of these two quantities
and these two quantities.
And since there are two
possibilities on each,
that gives us the four
possible outcomes.
And broadly, the idea
here is just that,
if the species are weakly
interfering with each other,
then what should happen?
Yes, then you should
get coexistence.
Coexistence is when
the betas are small.
Of course, this is
a concrete model,
so you have to define
what you mean by small.
And indeed, small
here ends up being
relative to the ratios of
these carrying capacities.
If the carrying capacities
are just equal to, say, 1,
then that's saying
that the betas-- sorry,
if the carrying capacities are
the same, then the simple way
to think about this is
just whether the betas
are larger or smaller than 1,
whether each species interferes
with the other species more than
a member of that other species.
So if carrying
capacities are the same,
that's what demarcates
the different zones.
So what we want to do is
take this sort of diagram
and try to figure out where
will the trajectories be
on this diagram?
Now, it's always good to
locate the fixed points.
The fixed points
of the system are?
And somebody, words?
How would we define fixed
points in this system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
Both lines intersect, right?
So when the dashed line
intersects the solid lines,
right?
So we have one such
fixed point here.
We have another fixed point here
and another fixed point here.
Have we figured
out the stability
of those fixed points?
No.
What's the stability
of this fixed point?
It's unstable, right?
Because we've
already, previously
assumed that these r's
are greater than 0.
We're assuming that
the species would be
able to survive on their own.
And that's actually
true for both species.
So this thing is unstable kind
of in both directions, right?
And what are the
eigenvectors associated
with this fixed point?
On the count of three,
draw, use your arms
like the hands of a clock
to indicate the directions
of the eigenvectors.
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
All right, all right.
There's no diagonals, right?
Of course, you could also.
I was waiting for somebody to
be kind of obnoxious and point
in the other direction.
A surprisingly not
obnoxious class we have.
So this is just saying
that, if you start out
just a little bit
of one species,
you'll just stay
with that species.
It makes sense.
Now, what do these lines
tell us about the directions
of the trajectories
or the orientations
of the trajectories?
Why did I draw them?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: These
trajectories are--
these are lines are nonlines.
And one of the
derivatives [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: One of the
derivatives, all right.
And in particular, let's
look at this line here.
Are the trajectories?
Again, we're going
to do our arms
to indicate the orientation
of the trajectories.
In particular, there's
a trajectory right here.
What direction will that
trajectory be pointing?
There's only going
to be one arm.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, we got a lot
of people not voting.
All right, that means we need to
turn our neighbors and discuss.
If you didn't vote,
it means, I think,
not following what
we're talking about.
Turn to somebody.
If your neighbor agrees with
you about which direction
you should be pointing
your arm, then
try to figure out
whether we know
which orientation the arrow
should actually be in.
[SIDE DISCUSSIONS]
PROFESSOR: We'll
figure this out.
[SIDE DISCUSSIONS]
PROFESSOR: Let's go
ahead and reconvene,
because it seems like some
people are being quiet.
But I'm not sure if
that's because they think
they know what's going on or
they're just very much unhappy
with the situation.
Let me see a fresh voting.
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
Definitely, it's going
up or down, right?
Because the definition of this
dashed line is that N1 dot
is equal to 0.
We don't know what N2 dot is.
We'll figure that
out in a moment.
But what we know is
that the trajectories
we should be something, lines
here, either up or down.
And we're going to find
that they're down but here.
Now, on this solid line,
quickly, the orientation of
trajectories.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, perfect.
So we know that
N2 dot is 0 here.
Now, an actual direction of
the trajectory, at this point,
right here.
Ready, three, two, one.
OK, good.
Because in the
absence of N2, we know
that species N1 should just
come to carrying capacity K1.
Same thing over here, we
should get arrows coming down.
So indeed, what you can see is
that the arrows are coming down
here.
That means they actually do
have to come down immediately
to the right of them.
Whereas over here,
the trajectory
is point right here, so
we can kind of figure out
that-- so they're coming here.
And from far away,
they're coming here.
And you can see that they
have to come across here.
And then they're going
to come into this point.
So this is going to be
our stable fixed point.
I'll color it in
to indicate that.
From here, they're going
to curve around though.
So if you start out right here,
you kind of do this business.
From here, we come in.
Are these lines allowed
to cross each other?
No.
Now, indeed, you
could actually see
here, what is the direction
of the other eigenvector
at this point?
Using a hand, arm,
ready, three, two, one.
Right, it's kind of
something in there.
Because there's all these
trajectories are coming here,
and then they approach this
fixed point from this point.
Because here, the
other eigenvector
is still horizontal, right?
Because we know, if we don't
have N2, then we just have N1.
But this other eigenvector
is not purely straight up.
The other one is along here,
because the trajectories
are coming in along that.
Does that make sense?
So in this case, we
should just be clear.
We are in a situation
where K1 over beta 12
is greater than K2.
Another way of writing that is
that beta 12 is less than K1
over K2.
So that means species 2 does
not strongly harm species 1.
Yet, we know that K1 is greater
than K2 divided by beta 21.
So that means that beta 21
is greater than K2 over K1.
This is telling us that
species 1 is strongly
harming species 2.
And that makes sense.
In that case, species 1 wins.
Does that outcome change
if we change the r values,
the division rates?
A is yes.
B is no.
I'm going to give
you 10 seconds.
What I just said, if
I change r's does that
change the outcome?
Ready, three, two, one.
So we've got a majority
of B. So the answer is no.
This statement that, in this
situation, species 1 dominates,
that's independent of the r's.
And what you see
is the conditions,
here, only depend on
the what's in here.
So the actual shape of those
trajectories will depend upon
the r's.
So if it's the case
that species 2 is just
a faster grower than
species 1, then you
might end up with
a situation where,
if you start with a
little bit of each,
you might come way
up here-- well, no.
I guess you might come
close to this fixed point.
So you might think
that it really looks
like species 2 is about to win.
But eventually, they'll
curve over and come back.
And indeed, in the Strogatz
book, one of the chapters
that I recommended, he has an
example of sheeps and rabbits,
the idea is that they
are competing species,
maybe eating similar foods.
I don't know if that's true.
But the rabbits can
divide more rapidly.
So here, the idea would be,
well, if the sheep can really
displace the rabbits,
because it's just bigger
and push them aside,
then what can happen
is that the rabbits
first divide rapidly.
It looks like they're
going to take over,
but, over time, eventually,
the sheep population kind of
grow up, and they start
displacing rabbits.
And you end up
excluding the rabbits.
This is this phenomenon
of competitive exclusion.
And depending upon the
context-- OK, that's an e--
this is either more or less
maybe formally phrased.
But the idea is that, if
there are two species that
are too similar,
and in particular,
if they're somehow
perfect competitors,
they're really just trying
to eat the same thing,
then you should
only end up with one
of the two species surviving.
And that's the
kind of idea here.
Although, I think, you can
argue about the mapping I think.
So this is one of
the four outcomes.
And of course, it
takes 15 minutes
to go through each
of these examples.
So we're not going to
go through all of them.
But you should be
able to, for a given
a combination of betas and
K's, be able to figure out,
using some combination
of algebra, derivatives,
fixed point stability analyses,
and drawing of things, well,
you should be able to
do all of the above.
Are there any questions
about where we are here?
AUDIENCE: I guess
that none of this
holds in the
stochastic [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
an interesting question.
AUDIENCE: For example, in that
case, if r2 is much bigger,
then you're going get almost,
very close to like K2,
and then maybe just the
last individual [INAUDIBLE]
and then you just
add that fixed point.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's certainly the
case that, once you
have stochastic
extinction-- the thing is
that, you would probably
be most susceptible
to stochastic extinction.
In the case you
were talking about,
you would be most susceptible
to stochastic extinction
when you're around
here, actually.
These trajectories are still
always moving up in N1 space.
I think I know
what you're saying.
We're going to maybe
zoom in onto this N1, N2.
Because we have this
unstable fixed point here.
And the claim was that, if
you start out over here,
then the trajectory might
look something like this.
And you'd say, oh, well,
you might go extinct here.
AUDIENCE: The idea
was just the statement
that [INAUDIBLE] r1, r2 are
very dynamical [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's true that,
I guess, things change.
There are a number of things
you might want to say.
First of all, this is a purely
continuous and deterministic
description of the setting.
It allows for
fractional individuals.
There's no shocks
or perturbations
that you have to worry about.
I guess the only
thing I wanted to say,
in regards to your
question, is that I
think the stochastic extinction
will not be dominated.
We're talking about stochastic
extinction of species 1.
It will not be dominated due
to a stochastic extinction here
but stochastic extinction
at the beginning.
I haven't drawn this very,
very well, but, in this case,
I think these
trajectories are always
are going up in numbers
of the 1 species, which
means that you're most
likely to experience
stochastic extinction
at the beginning.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: r1 and r2
should still really
mess with stochastic
extinction a lot, right?
Because the larger r1
and r2 are the quicker
we get out of the regime
of stochastic extinction.
PROFESSOR: That's all true.
We have to be careful
about many of these things.
In particular, if you go and
you do a stochastic simulation
of this, so let's say you plug
this thing into a Gillespie
simulation, can you get
stochastic extinction?
A yes, or B no, ready,
three, two, one.
No.
So the answer is no but why?
AUDIENCE: It depends.
If you take r
combination [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So right now, as written,
there's no death.
Although, I guess you could
say that this a death.
There's a question of
how you partition things.
So in principle, this is the
difference between the growth
and the death rate.
But the most straightforward
way of doing such a simulation
is that you put this whole thing
in here as a rate for birth.
Somebody is going to say, ah,
that's not how I was going
to do the simulation, right?
Well, that's probably how
you were going to do it.
AUDIENCE: That's a terrible way.
PROFESSOR: But if you did
that, if there's only birth,
then you can't get stochastic
extinction, obviously.
But in general-- and
this is one of things
we spend our time
a lot time thinking
about in this semester--
there are multiple ways
of doing kind of a
stochastic simulation
from a deterministic equation.
And this thing, you
could be more explicit
and say, oh, this
thing is really
a B2 minus a D2, so a birth rate
minus a death rate for example.
And form the standpoint of
a differential equation,
it doesn't make any difference.
But if you do the
Fokker-Planck approximation
or you do a
simulation or whatnot,
then these lead to
different things.
In particular, the rate of,
say, stochastic extinction
here increases as B and D
increase, because that leads
to more of these fluctuations.
So there are many things that
are different once you include
the stochastic dynamics.
But it's always good to get
a base sense of the dynamics
from the standpoint of just
deterministic differential
equations before you think
too much about the stochastic
dynamics, because otherwise
you get overwhelmed quickly.
Any other questions about that?
What I want to do is just
spend a little bit of time
to think about the more
generalized case of more
species.
And in particular, we could
convert this set of equations.
We can normalize by each of
their carrying capacities.
And we can convert
a set of equations
to look something like this.
So now we just have Xi
dot is equal to-- there's
some ri Xi, 1 minus.
And what we can actually
do is normalize everything
so that it's just
written like this.
And normally, what we
assume is that we've
done things such that alpha
i i is equal to 1 for all i.
So this is just saying that
this is the normalization such
that each species
inhibits itself in a way
that it's just give a
simple logistic growth.
And it's going to be logistic
growth with a carrying
capacity equal to 1.
And then once you've
done that, then a species
inhibits itself
with alpha i i 1.
And then everything comes down
to what this alpha matrix is.
And I would say that, as
always, it's really very, very
important that you
can go back and forth
between the non-dimensionalized
versions of equations
and the base version.
This was something that,
on exam number two,
there were quite a lot of
problems where we asked about,
how does the
parameter change when
you change the strength of
expression or this or that,
right?
So this is something that
I think is very important.
Because this comes up a lot.
So in this case,
the alpha matrix
tells you kind of everything.
And then there are
a number of things
that, well, the
mathematicians have proven
about these sorts of equations.
And I just want to point you
towards some of those things
to think about.
So first, I'm considering a
case where, again, alpha i
j is greater than 0,
again, for all i and ji,
or greater than or equal to 0.
So some of them can be 0.
But the interactions, when
they exist, are competitive.
So first, if you start
out in the region where
all of the species start,
between 0 and 1, then
you stay in that region.
If this is true initially,
then it will be true forever.
That's good.
Negative abundances, you maybe
were not so worried about.
But it's not as obvious that
you can't get above one,
because there's nothing
saying that, in principle, you
couldn't have
started there, right?
Or in principle, you
couldn't have gotten there?
And certainly, it's
physical to think
about starting outside
of that region,
because we often talk
about carrying capacities
as something that's like.
If you think about, this is
an Xi as a function of time.
So in these situations, it's not
crazy to think about something
above the carrying capacity.
But this mathematical statement
about the Latka-Volterra
framework is that,
if you start out
with everything below
its carrying capacity,
then everything will
always stay there.
And all the dynamics occur--
this is for i equal to 1 to N
Do I want to use a
big N or little n?
Does it matter?
So this is big N,
different species.
The dynamics occur on
an N minus one manifold.
If we have many
mathematicians, they
can explain what this
technically means.
But basically,
what it's saying is
that there's going to be some
N minus 1 dimensional surface
or volume or whatnot
where all the dynamics are
going end up being on.
And what that means is that,
in particular, a limit cycle
requires two
dimensions, requires
2D, which means that
to get a limit cycle
requires-- so then N has to
be greater than or equal to 3
to get a limit cycle.
Can you see what I'm saying?
Whereas chaos
requires 3D, and that
means that N has to be
greater than or equal to 4.
And indeed, you can get limit
cycles with N equal to 3.
And you get chaos
with N equal to 4.
There's another
theorem that says
that any dynamics are possible
for N equal to 5 or larger.
And chaos seems as much as
I would want to ask for.
But there's,
apparently, a 4D torus,
something that is different.
This is something to think
about in your spare time.
Well, you know, like
a lot of things.
And this is worth spending
a moment talking about.
First of all, so here's
a two dimensional thing.
The special thing, as
you might remember,
about continuous dynamics is
that these trajectories are not
allowed to cross
each other, right?
Which means that you just can't
draw a chaotic trajectory,
because you're going to have
to cross yourself again.
And that's also why a
limit cycle requires two,
because we originally tried
to draw a limit cycle in one
dimension, and it didn't work.
Do you remember this?
And the same thing with--
you can imagine, here's
a nice limit cycle.
And that could be stable.
Oh, and incidentally,
you were right about.
I was getting confused about
the Poincare-Bendixson theorem.
Because I think there
are these funny things.
It wasn't.
OK, well, you know,
all these people
that complain about what I say.
Because if you have the
trajectories coming in,
then what I said was that, if
you had an unstable fixed point
coming out, then you
could draw this region,
then you could be
guaranteed that there
was a limit cycle in there.
But you cannot, just based
on what I had said, say that,
if it's a stable fixed point,
then you won't get a limit
cycle.
I mean in some other cases you
can prove that it doesn't work.
Particularly, like in
the Latka-Volterra,
there in one of
the crossings, it's
now going to be a
stable fixed point.
In that situation, you
can prove, mathematically,
that you can never get a
limit cycle oscillation
because of some divergence
condition of some function
and so forth.
But in the example that
I was telling you about,
in the predator-prey, it was
true in that particular case
that, when that thing is stable,
you don't get oscillations.
And when it's unstable, you do.
But both directions
do not follow
from the Poincare-Bendixson.
This is a limit cycle.
Now, in a chaotic situation, you
have to be able to do something
where you kind of
come around and then,
every now and then,
you kind go over here.
And then you go
around and around.
Something crazy happens.
But you can see that
this situation doesn't
work if it's only 2D, right?
Do you see why I'm saying that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You don't?
You don't agree.
It's just, if it's 2D, then
these lines cannot cross.
So you need to a
third dimension,
so that they can just shoot
above and below each other.
AUDIENCE: And what's
with the definition?
Because you can come
up with trajectories,
like you can have trajectories
that asymptotically approach
the limit cycle but that
never cross themselves, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Those are obviously
not chaotic, but the y--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is not actually
class in non-linear dynamics,
so we're not.
So normally, you characterize
this Lyapunov exponent,
which tells you about
how the phase space is
kind of growing or shrinking.
In the case that you
were just talking about,
that's a case where all the
trajectories come together.
Because in this case where this
trajectory comes into the limit
cycle, if you draw like
a blob of phase space,
it's going to come
together over time.
Whereas in a chaotic system, if
you have a blob of phase space,
it's going to diverge and
fold and do all the craziness.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you said
[INAUDIBLE] essentially
you need n greater
than or equal to 3.
Is that just for this--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yes.
So this is in this
Latka-Volterra.
Because, in general, you
can get a limit cycle
with two equations.
And that's with the 2D.
And in general, you get a
chaos with three equations
or three variables.
But in the Latka-Volterra model,
it requires three and four,
respectively.
That doesn't mean that
every four species
Latka-Volterra will have chaos.
But it means that it's
possible to get one.
And I think one thing
that's just rather striking
is that this really is kind of
the simplest, possible model
you can ever write
down describing
how species might
interact or variables
might interact or whatnot.
And so it's really kind
of incredible to me
that you get all
these crazy dynamics.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask
about the n minus 1 thing.
This dynamic [INAUDIBLE]
n minus 1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Over here
it just looks to me
like-- we have n equals
2 and the dynamics
are occuring on a plane,
on a two-dimensional plane.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The transience or
whatever can occur.
It requires the full N
dimensions to describe.
Because you can
start-- to describe
all of the trajectories, clearly
requires all dimensions, right?
Because anywhere
you start, you have
to have specify it
by five dimensions.
But the dynamics, as
far as like-- and here,
there aren't even any dynamics.
I think that you go to a point.
AUDIENCE: What do
you mean by dynamics?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I agree that there
is a-- so in the case
of the limit cycles
and so forth, this is really
like, at steady state,
it's doing something.
So here, steady state, it
only goes to the fixed points.
But if you have a three
dimensional system,
then you can have it steady
state, the trajectories
on like a plane.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it because
there's like some concept
of [INAUDIBLE] that can be
[INAUDIBLE] for the system?
PROFESSOR: I don't think
that that-- I'm not
aware of that being the case.
But I'm hesitant to
say that it's not true.
I want to switch
gears a little bit
and think about three
species interactions
and, in particular the
three species interactions
when they're non-transitive.
Because this is thought
to be potentially
a significant stabilizer for
diversity in populations.
So this is non-transitive
interactions.
And we often just say
rock-paper-scissors.
Is everybody from a cultural
that plays rock-paper-scissors?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this is a
true, human universal.
Although I think that what we
call it does vary and so forth.
You know how sometimes
the linguists
try to find this ur-language
that our ancestors spoke
50,000 years ago or whatever?
I think that you
probably do something
similar with
rock-paper-scissors,
because it seems to be
a pretty common theme.
But the idea here is
that you have-- wait,
which direction does it go?
So paper beats rock,
scissors beats paper,
but rock beats the scissors.
So you can imagine that
this kind of dynamic
can be captured in the
Latka-Volterra type framework.
So you just have to set
up these betas or alphas
so that this is true.
And again, the way
to think about this
would be-- the simplest thing is
to think about it as dominance.
So if you have the rock
species and the scissor species
together, then the rock species
will drive the scissor species
extinct and so forth.
Now, this is the
kind of situation
that, in principle, can lead
to very complicated dynamics
in multi-species ecosystems
that, at least in many models,
can stabilize the coexistence
of multiple species via some
of these complex, crazy
dynamics that we were just
talking about.
I would say that, as a
mechanism for the stabilization
of diversity, I don't
know how convincing
that is in terms of being what
explains why it is there's
so much diversity outside, when
you look outside the window.
But, at least, it's
in principle true.
And one of the topics
of these papers--
certainly the one
you just read--
is that
rock-paper-scissors, i.e.
non-transitive
interactions on their own,
may not be sufficient,
but, in the presence
of spatial structure,
maybe it does
allow for long-term coexistence
of these species or strategies
and so forth.
And again, it's not always
clear in these situations
whether you're
thinking about ecology,
where these are
different species,
or you're thinking
about evolution, where
these are different genotypes.
And indeed, in the Kerr
paper that you read,
these are all E. coli.
So it's all one species,
it's just that they
have different mutations.
So that's really
rock-paper-scissors
in the context of evolution.
Whereas in the male
mating strategies
paper by Curt Lively, that's
more of an ecological context,
but it still is evolution
within the species.
Because these mating
strategies are heritable.
I did tell you the base idea
of this lizard mating strategy
business?
Or did I never say
anything about that?
Not really?
OK.
For some reason, I thought
that I'd alluded to it.
Well, let me explain it to you.
I think it's kind of
an incredible paper.
So this is a paper
by my Curt Lively.
So it's Sinervo and Lively.
It was Nature in '96.
And it's called "The
Rock-Paper-Scissors
Game and the Evolution of
Alternative Male Strategies."
So what was known
is that there are
many examples of alternative
mating strategies in males.
In particular, it's rather
common that there are,
what you might call,
territorial males
and what they often
call sneaker males.
This is observed in fish
and various land animals.
And in many of the cases,
these sneaker males
really do look
phenotypically like females.
And this has been measured
using various kinds
of observational,
experimental approaches.
There's often what you
call negative frequency
dependent selection
between these strategies.
The sneakers can
often, when rare,
spread in population of the
territorial and vice versa.
But this was, at the
least the first case
I'm aware of where these
ideas had been demonstrated,
that there were really
three strategies.
And the three
strategies implemented,
one of these rock-paper-scissors
interactions.
I want to maybe make
a little more space.
If you guys are
available after class,
I encourage you to come
up and look at the paper,
because they actually
have pictures of them,
so you can identify
the sneaker males.
Because they actually
look different
based on the coloring
of their throat.
So these are lizards that live
in the mountains up outside
of the Bay Area in
California, in Merced County.
They're side-blotched lizards.
I don't know
anything about that.
And what they showed
was that there's
these guys with orange throats
that are kind of aggressive.
And they defend a
very large territory
with a large number of females.
And they fight off
any males that come.
Then there are the dark blue.
Sorry, I should have
put that over here.
So there are other lizards here
that are dark blue throats.
And these guys are less
aggressive with smaller
territories.
So you can guess, if it were
just the orange-throated guys
and the dark-- and these are
genetically encoded strategies,
in the sense that they
do seem to be passed on,
and it's determined by the genes
that the male inherits-- less
aggressive and small territory.
Can you guess which one
wins between these two,
against each other?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: The two
aggressive ones
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but if you just
have the two aggressive ones?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This guy's going
to beat this one, right?
That's just because this
aggressive male has a larger
territory, and they
pass on more genes
than the less aggressive ones.
However, what they found is that
there's a third mating strategy
here, which are
these sneaker males.
And they indeed look
like the females.
They have these yellow
stripes on their throats.
They look like the female,
and they have no territory.
Sneaker males, so they
don't defend any territory.
Instead, they just
sneak into the territory
of the other males
and try to mate
with the females
in that territory.
And what they show is that,
over the course of seven years,
in the mountains
of Merced, they see
that the frequency
of these things
goes through an
entire oscillation.
So they see just over one
period of this oscillation.
And their argument is
that, although it's true
that the aggressive males can
outcompete the less aggressive
ones, the sneakers
actually outcompete
these aggressive
ones, basically,
because these
aggressive males, it's
just too large of a
territory for them
to effectively defend it.
So the sneakers can
actually outcompete
the aggressive males.
Yet the less aggressive ones
can outcompete the sneakers,
because they are trying to
defend a smaller territory.
So they basically
measured the frequency
of these strategies and
also the number of females
in the different territories,
from 1990 to '96 or so,
and saw that this thing kind
of went around in some circle
in this frequency space of
alternative male strategies.
Kind of an incredible paper.
So the idea here is this
is a situation where
it is non-transitive.
So there's this
rock-paper-scissors type
dynamic.
And it's also spatial,
because these lizards are
in some particular place,
they have some territory
and so forth.
And in this other paper,
by Benjamin Kerr, what
he wanted to do was try
to understand something
about what the role of
that spatial structure
might be in maintaining
the diversity.
So in this case, the argument
was that, if you go out
and you look at these
lizards, the reason
that you see all three
of these strategies
is because of this
rock-paper-scissors dynamic.
If one of the strategies
becomes more rare,
it's going to have an advantage
relative to the others.
It's going to spread.
And what Benjamin
Kerr wanted to explore
is whether that statement
could be made-- somehow
you can distinguish between
whether the spatial component
is important or not.
Of course, it's hard to do that
in the case of the lizards,
but he was able
to implement this
in the case some chemical
warfare behavior in bacteria.
So in this paper by
Kerr, and it's also
a Nature paper from 2002.
So this paper is
called "Local Dispersal
of Promotes Biodiversity
in a Real Life
Game of Rock-Paper-Scissors."
So you guys read it.
So what were the
three strategies?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So C is
the colicin producers.
Incidentally, just
this colicin production
is kind of an incredible
phenomenon already.
So these are proteins that
are produced that bind
to other bacteria and can often
make pores in the membrane
and kill them.
But the amazing thing about
the colicin production
is that in E. coli
and other gram
negative bacteria, the only
way that these colicins are
released is by cell lysis.
So it's not just that
the cell is engaging
in some costly behavior in
order to make this protein that
will kill other cells.
But the only way that
the toxin is released
is by the cell
actually bursting open.
So it's clear then that
this has to be supported
by some kind of group level or
kin-selection kind of argument.
This can never be good
for the individual,
because the individual
has had to spill its guts
in order to harm other cells.
So the only way that
this can be supported
is by inhibiting the
growth of competitors
and allowing your
kind of kin mates
or other cells that also have
this plasmid, and, therefore,
also the immunity protein,
allowing them to grow better.
So this is a very neat
example of an altruistic,
kind of warlike behavior.
So this is one of
the strategies.
What was the other two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Resistant.
So there's R,
which is resistant.
And between the C
and R, who wins?
AUDIENCE: R.
PROFESSOR: R, that's right.
There might be some
costs associated
with being resistant,
but the cost
is not as large as
actually bursting open.
What's the last one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sensitive.
PROFESSOR: Sensitive, perfect.
So this is just the
normal bacteria.
And the argument is
that there's often
a cost to be resistant, which
means that sensitive bacteria
will outcompete resistant.
Yet, if it's just the sensitive
and the colicinogenic strains,
then this strain can
beat this strain.
So this is the idea of the
rock-paper-scissors game
in this system.
They do say that,
in some situations,
the fitnesses are such
that it's like this.
And it's good to take
these sentences seriously,
because, if they thought that
every time that you isolate
a resistant bacterium,
that it would satisfy this,
they would have said, when you
do this, this is what you see.
Their phrasing tells
you that actually,
depending upon which strain
you get here or there,
you may or may not see this.
So you have to be careful.
Just because there's a nice
paper that's written about this
doesn't mean that, if you go out
and you find particular strains
that have these properties,
that it will always
yield this particular outcome.
So they argue that these
strains, just because they
have a non-transitive
interaction,
does not necessarily
mean that they
will be able to coexist in
a well mixed environment
in particular.
And in their simulations
and the experiments,
where they did experiments
in a test tube,
which strain died first?
The sensitive strain.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, right?
And the other thing to remember
is that these strains, there's
no reason that they should
be accurately described
by a Latka-Volterra
type formulation.
And in particular, it
could just be the case
that, if you have
enough producers
and they make enough
of the colicin,
then the sensitive
cells are just all dead.
And that will, in general,
be hard to capture
in this sort of framework.
So the idea is that if you
start with a bunch of N's, N
for each of these
three, then first you
see that the
sensitive cells die.
And once the sensitive
cells have died,
then you're really just
playing an interaction
between these two.
In that case, you get the
colcinogenic strain dying,
and you're left with just
the resistant strain.
One thing I want to
caution you about,
though, is that, just
because in this experiment
they saw that coexistence of
three rock-paper-scissors type
strains was not possible in
a well mixed environment,
it does not mean that it
will always be the case.
This is a very well
known paper in the field.
And the thing is that it's easy
to forget what a paper shows
and what it doesn't show.
So what this shows is
that there is maybe
a set of these
three strains that
have a rock-paper-scissors
type interaction.
And in those particular
three strains,
that are interacting
in this particular way,
via colicin killing
da-duh, then they
don't coexist in this particular
well mixed and maybe other well
mixed environments as well.
But this does not
necessarily show
that any rock-paper-scissors
interaction
in a well mixed environment
will not support coexistence.
And in particular, you might
remember, in Martin Nowak's
book, there are very
reasonable equations
that display rock-paper-scissors
type interactions that
can lead to coexistence.
So you can kind of
spiral in that space
to a state of coexistence.
So it's possible.
But in this situation,
it doesn't happen.
Can somebody remind us how
they implemented the spatially
structured environment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So they used agar plates.
They did this thing where
they took this plate,
and they kind of used a
hexagonal grid of some sort.
Is it actually hexagonal?
Yeah.
I don't know how they decided
on the original order,
but they said, OK, here
is a sensitive, sensitive,
resistant,
colicinogenic, resistant.
I don't know, whatever.
So they filled it up.
They put maybe 20 different
kind of patches there.
And then they
basically, each day,
they just used one
of these velvets,
that we often use to
do replica plating.
And then they just kind of
took off some of the cells
and put it on a fresh plate.
And then they did
this for a week or so.
And then they saw that
there was some sense
that there was a
spatial dynamic taking
place, where the
spatial structure was
kind of reminiscent of this.
The sensitive kind of
moved into the resistant.
The resistant kind of moved
into the colicinogenic.
Colicinogenic kind of
moved into the sensitive.
But they couldn't
actually see all of those,
because two of the strains, they
said, grew to similar density.
That was between the sensitive
and the resistant, right?
So visually, they
can only distinguish
the colicinogenic strain
relative to the others.
But what they found, though,
is that, over a similar amount
of time, they got
coexistence of all three.
So R, C, S, kind
of all-- the number
is just a function of time--
stuck around in this spatially
structured environment.
So their argument is
that, in some cases maybe,
this non-transitive
interaction is not
sufficient to maintain
diversity in a population,
whether it's genetic diversity
or species diversity.
But it may be that
it's very important
to have this spatial component.
If you're curious
about these things,
there's also a nice
computational study
done by Erwin Frey, who studied
these rock-paper-scissors
dynamics as a function
of the mobility
of the individual agents.
And in that study,
he found that there
was sort of a critical
level of mobility
in which you kind of switch
from a spatially structured
environment with coexistence
to, above some mobility,
you end up losing the diversity,
because it kind of goes
into this well mixed regime.
So if you're curious
about these things,
you can look up Erwin's paper.
Are there any questions
about what they did here,
what you think it means?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You said you
couldn't use [INAUDIBLE].
How did they know if
it was [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: They can just scrape
off everything and plate.
AUDIENCE: And then you can tell?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Because, well, then
you can ask, oh, we're
those guys sensitive
to colicin or not?
AUDIENCE: Why not actually
just inject them with colicin?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Or plate them on
something with colicin.
This is a system that has
been very influential,
but it's really
not yet or has not
been a domesticated kind of
model system in the sense
that they are not nice,
fluorescent proteins.
This is not on a
nice cloning plasmid.
It was a natural plasmid.
And this resistant strain,
the way that they get it is,
basically, they take
some sensitive cells,
and they add colicin.
Let's say they supernatant
from here, and they ask,
which cells grow> and then
that's a resistant cell.
And it's genetically resistant.
But then each one's
going to different.
They have done sequencing.
It's a surface receptor that
the colicin maybe uses to go in
or other things.
But indeed, we actually
did some experiments
with some of these strains.
And it's a little bit messy.
And I think that there's a
sense that the field maybe
needs to just make some nice
plasmids, with nice colors,
so that we can really
distinguish things.
Because I think that this
system, despite 500 citations
or so, almost none
of those citations
are experimental papers
really exploring this thing.
Because I think that it still
is just a little bit messy.
And I think that it's
also a very pretty system
to explore these ideas.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, why can't you
distinguish these?
And they say it's because
they're similar densities.
I don't even know
if that's even.
Of course, well, if you
added sensitive cells here
and sensitive cells
here and they grew up,
it's likely you're not
going to see a boundary.
And just more
generally, if you take
similar strains-- and these
are rather similar strains,
this just has some mutation
relative to this-- then
you won't, often, see a boundary
when the colonies kind of grow
up.
AUDIENCE: So they just
didn't see boundaries.
It's not like they didn't see--
PROFESSOR: So they saw
there were cells there,
but they couldn't necessarily
say that it was true
that the sensitive
cells were kind
of spreading into the resistant
cell region, because they
couldn't see the boundary.
So in the last 20
minutes here, 15, 20,
I just want to say a few things
about these population waves.
For many, many purposes,
there are strong arguments
to be made that, in the context
of evolution or ecology,
spatial dynamics matter.
And the way that we often think
about the spatial dynamics
is via some effective
diffusive process.
And that's convenient,
because we know
a lot about how to model it.
But it's also maybe a
reasonable description
of the motion of animals and
other living things over length
scales that are large
compared to the movements
of the animals.
So what we do is we take
some equation, such as,
well, we often have, say, dN/dt.
So this is going to be
about population waves.
So we take our standard thing
where we say, oh, here's
r N 1 minus N/K.
And then we just want to
add some spatial dynamic.
So what we're going to
do is we're going to say,
now, the derivative,
now it's a density.
So we're going to use a
little n, just for fun.
And we might still use
a K just for simple.
But then we have to add
some diffusive term.
So there still is going to
be a local carrying capacity.
Now this is in terms of
density of the organism.
And we're going to assume that
there is some diffusive type
motion of the organism.
Now this is this is, of course,
going over the life-scale
over which the animals
are actually doing things
over shorter time scales.
So it could be that
different organisms
have very different
modes of motility.
In some cases they walk
or swim, in some cases
they just get picked
up by a passing deer.
So there are a
wide range of ways
in which organisms move around.
But if you look at it over kind
of longer length time scales,
then maybe it doesn't matter.
And certainly, if it's an
unbiased kind of motion,
with motility
being well-behaved,
i.e., if the probability
distribution of these steps,
as long as it's not long-tailed.
Similarly, Oskar Hallatschek,
over at Berkeley,
has been doing a lot
of fun work looking
at epidemic spread
in cases where
this kernel, the kind of
step size distribution,
has long tails.
It leads to qualitatively
different behaviors.
So if you're curious about such
things, check out Oskar's work.
But for normal kind of the
step size distributions,
then the central limit
theorem type considerations
just tell you that you
can maybe just look
at it like this over time
spatial scales that are bigger.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But is it a unique
correlation in your step?
Because the central
limit theorem, as long
as the variance-- I
guess, you're saying?
PROFESSOR: That's why
I'm saying long-tailed.
AUDIENCE: If the
variance is infinite?
PROFESSOR: Exactly Yeah, so
that's what I was saying.
And indeed, people argue, in
the case of disease spread,
with modern air
travel and so forth,
that the probability
distribution
of kind of step sizes
for infected individuals,
over the next week,
is long-tailed, right?
Because there's a fair
chance that you're just
going to stay around
your local neighborhood,
but there's a
smaller chance you're
going to go to the
other side of town.
But you might go to a
business trip over in DC.
At some small right, though,
you also fly to South Africa
and go to a conference.
So all of these things have
reasonable probabilities,
and so there are arguments that
this is kind of some power law
type distribution.
And in those cases,
you don't necessarily
have finite variance, and
so then you can't just
put everything under the rug.
But we first want to
understand what happens here,
and then we can--
well, we're not
going to-- but then
other people can
think more deeply about what
happens in fancier situations.
It is worth saying,
though, that this approach,
I mean it looks very
physics-y, in the sense that
physicists like simple
equations where we add diffusion
and so forth.
But this is not what a
physicist came up with.
These are classic ideas
in evolution and ecology.
The solution to this was
originally done by Fisher.
So this was in the 1920s or so.
So a long time ago,
originally to try
to understand not the
spread of a population
but the spread of a beneficial
allele in a spatial population.
And once again, this
highlights the deep connections
between evolution and ecology.
You can have a
genetic wave in space
of a of a beneficial
mutant spreading,
or you can have a population
wave of an invasive species
or whatnot, and you end up
getting very similar dynamics.
So the basic idea,
here, is that,
if you look at the density
as a function of position.
If start with, there's
one individual.
What's going to happen?
It's going to start
dividing, right?
So we kind of get up.
And it's going to come up.
And eventually it's
going to saturate
at this carrying capacity, K.
And then you end up getting
these spreading population
waves that look like this.
And the reason we're
calling it a wave
is because the shape of this
front is the same over time.
So it can really to be described
as some function x minus vt.
And we are going to,
maybe, typically assume
that we're in a situation
where we don't have
to think about the
left and the right,
because it's just
too complicated.
So we'll just imagine it being
that it's at saturation here,
and then we're looking
at some front that's
moving to the right.
Now, by dimensional
analysis, we should
be able to figure out what
the velocity is going to be.
Remember how much we
liked dimensional analysis
in this class?
Yes.
So what we're
going to do is I'll
give you some
characters that you're
going to be able to
use in your quest.
So we can use r, K, D. I'll give
you a square root in case you
find it useful.
And you can raise something
to the second power as well.
So what you can do is you're
going to set up your cards
so that when I look at it,
from the left to the right,
it will describe the
velocity of this wave.
I'll give you 30 seconds.
So this is dimensional analysis
for this wave velocity.
All right, do you
need more time?
Yes?
OK, that's fine.
All right, let's
go ahead and vote.
Construct your answer, remember,
from me, from left to right.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right.
We have trouble.
A key skill is being
able to imagine yourself
in someone else's shoes.
So if I'm viewing--
but that's OK.
So we have, here, this is
kind of units of 1 over time.
This is what length
squared over time.
Whereas this is a density.
If we want something that
is a length over time,
then we're going to end up
having to take r times D
and take a square root.
So this should be DAC,
which is a square root
of-- of course, it depends
on how you're entering it
into your calculator, if you
have scientific calculator
or something else, maybe.
And indeed, it ends
up, there's a 2 here.
So this is the velocity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I see
what you're saying.
But it ends up not being true.
These derivative signs
don't have any units.
So this still has
units of a density
divided by a length squared.
So for unit purposes, you just
look at this thing and at this.
This squared does mean
there's a length squared
in the denominator, but this
squared doesn't do anything.
So D is still a length
squared over time.
So this is the famous
Fisher velocity.
There are some
mathematical subtleties
to all of this that we're
not really going to get into.
I don't know.
I'm having trouble-- velocity.
There are a few
features to highlight.
If the organism grows
faster, the wave
is going to spread faster.
That make sense?
If it has a larger mobility,
it also moves faster.
That makes sense.
Of course, the velocity is
given by both of those things.
So this wave coming out really
is a population level property.
Because it's not just growth.
It's not just motion.
It's a result of the coupled
division and diffusion
that leads to this
population wave spreading.
Importantly, to first
order, it doesn't
depend on the carrying
capacity, at least
within the deterministic regime.
AUDIENCE: It's interesting that,
if the reproductive rate goes
to 0, suddenly the
population stops spreading.
PROFESSOR: So first of all.
You'd say, oh, it would be
sort of surprising if it really
kept on spreading in
the absence of growth.
But what you're
pointing out is that,
if you just, at one
moment, turn off division,
then there will
still be diffusion.
It'll still keep on going.
But this is the velocity
of a wave when it's a wave.
When it's described by
a function like this.
So it's true that you
could turn off division,
and it'll still diffuse.
But then the shape
is changing as well.
I'm going to draw a
few lines describing
possible populations.
Now, let's assume that they
have the same motion, diffusion.
I want to know, which one
has the largest velocity?
Is it A, B, C, D?
It's the same diffusion.
Per capita growth rate as
a function of the density
for three different organisms.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, so I'd say we have
a fair number of B's, D's.
It seems like it's B versus D.
Now, this is tricky because D,
we have not explicitly
considered here.
But it turns out that the
answer is B. Certainly,
between these three,
these are all really
logistic growth functions.
And so from the standpoint
of here, it's just this r.
And r is the division
rate at 0 cell density.
The per capita growth
rate at 0 cell density
is what determines the
velocity in a Fisher wave.
And indeed, that's
true even if there's
no decrease in the
growth up right until you
get to some carrying capacity.
And indeed, all of these
cases, the division rate
and the growth rate that's
relevant for the velocity
is when it hits this axis.
And indeed, all of these
waves are described as Fisher
or pulled waves.
Because there's a sense
that the entire wave
is determined by the
front of the wave.
So we drew this profile.
I didn't do that very well.
Here, this is an exponential.
And the exponential actually
is what's pulling this wave.
There ends up being a
characteristic length
scale here that is the
square root of D/r.
So this is the length
scale of the exponential.
And the velocity
and the length scale
are only functions
of the division
rate in the limit
below cell density
or low density of organism.
The shape of what goes
on here changes, indeed,
the bulk properties of
the wave, but doesn't
change the velocity.
And I just want to make
one comparison of all this
to-- because there's another
qualitatively different kind
of wave, which is a
so-called pushed wave.
And that's what happens
if you have an Allee
effect, particularly like
a strong Allee effect.
If this thing looks-- like
this is certainly possible.
This is an Allee effect.
Now, if you just said, oh,
the only thing that matters is
the growth rate at low cell
density, you would say, oh,
this thing cannot
possibly expand.
Although it turns out
that it still is possible.
And in this
situation, it would be
called a push wave, where
your profile somehow
maybe looks kind of similar.
But instead of it
being the front
of the wave that's
pulling the wave,
it's diffusion around the bulk.
Because the bulk
is the part that
is actually happily growing.
Because the front, here,
in this case, is dying.
Yet it still is possible to
have a positive velocity.
And so this is, then, a
qualitatively different kind
of population expansion.
So cooperatively
growing populations
expand very differently
from logistically growing
populations.
And one of things that the
reading in Physics Today
talked about is
these different rates
of loss of heterozygocity and so
forth in different populations.
And as you might
expect, the pulled waves
have a smaller effective
population size
than the pushed waves, because,
here, the relevant population
is at the front if
it's a low density.
Whereas here, the
relevant population
is the bulk that's
at high density.
With that, I think
we should quit.
But I will see you on Tuesday.
And we'll talk about this
neutral theory in ecology.
Thanks.